[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de votre fidélité
bienvenue dans le grand jt des
territoires voici les titres de
l'actualité de cette édition les
campagnes de tests trois villes vont
mener une campagne massive de tests de
toute la population saint-etienne dans
la loire en fait partie tous les détails
dans un instant avec tl7 ouverte quand
même ce sont les stations de ski qui
ouvrent leurs portes malgré
l'interdiction des remontées mécaniques
dans les vosges vous le verrez les idées
ne manquent pas pour se diversifier
enfin les cadeaux de noël grâce à la
poste car enfin noël approche
comment donner des cadeaux à vos proches
malgré le confinement il suffit de les
envoyer par la poste il fallait y penser
idée simple mais faites vite les bureaux
sont pris d'assaut
nous partons à saint-etienne comme je
vous disais dans les titres cette ville
fait partie des trois villes choisies
pour la campagne massive de test avec le
havre est avec lille et dans l'attenté
des modalités pratiques qui restent à
définir
cette opération concrétise la volonté de
toute une région
adrien betty pour t elle cette télé
loire 7 sur place les stéphanois auront
donc la possibilité de se faire tester
d'ici la fin de l'année
mais tous ne semblent pas intéressés
n'ont pas ce que va je trouve que ça
sert à pas grand-chose parce que on se
fait dépister une semaine après on peut
ré à voir et à chaque fois faudrait
payer donc ya pas forcément un intérêt
puisque nouvelles ont fait pas avec ma
famille tous à mes parents on est
toujours ensemble donc
qu'on les opposants tout commencera
ensemble je pense que ça vaut pas comme
on était l'épicentre
au début de l'épidémie de l'épidémie je
pense que c'est important c'était normal
voilà qu'ils fassent ça c'est à dire
qu'on était quand même un vrai donc
peut-être que je dis pas que c'est mal
mais pour moi enfin voilà pour moi c'est
non où quand comment les modalités
pratiques restent encore à préciser même
si certains aspects de la campagne
commence à émerger
on va quand même être avant tout sur des
tests pcr et des tests antigénique et on
va être sur grosso - la deuxième
quinzaine de décembre avec des barnums
qu'on a vu comme on a pu le voir
ailleurs et avec l'utilisation de la
réserve sanitaire pour pouvoir mobiliser
des soignants pour pouvoir faire des
tests il y a deux semaines c'est laurent
wauquiez le président de la région qui
lancé l'idée d'un dépistage massif
une idée qui n'avait pas plu aux députés
de la majorité
je trouve ça particulièrement ridicule
et en plus particulièrement coûteux pour
un résultat scientifique absolument
inintéressant
aujourd'hui julien bobroff 6 expliqué
regrette encore un manque de
concertation et la communiquer comme
d'habitude mais il n'a rien structuré
c'est à dire que le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui son organisation se fait
sans les autorités de santé avec la
mobilisation locale
il a il le dit d'ailleurs une plaquette
qui est sorti il a acheté des tests mais
après moi je ne sais toujours pas
aujourd'hui comment vont être payés ces
tests est ce que c'est la sécurité
sociale qui va les payer en ce qu'on
fait déjà du dépistage massif là la
question c'est d'avoir du dépistage
épidémiologique localisé en particulier
sur la métropole stéphanoise
cet après midi une réunion rassemble l
agence nationale de la santé et le maire
de saint-etienne gaël perdriau qui n'a
pas encore répondu à nos sollicitations
ouverte malgré tout nous partons dans
les vosges maintenant où la station de
ski de gérardmer la mauselaine a ouvert
ses portes en proposant diverses
activités
mais évidemment pas de ski alpin faute
de pouvoir faire fonctionner les
remontées mécaniques vous le savez sur
décision gouvernementale
les premières réactions avec ce
reportage des équipes
viens vosges sur place dans la neige la
neige est là et il compte bien en
profiter ce week end à la station de la
mauselaine à gérardmer pour une
ouverture exceptionnelle exceptionnelle
car de telles conditions d'enneigement
précoce ne se présente pas tous les ans
mais surtout parce que les remontées
mécaniques sont à l'arrêt sur décision
gouvernementale pas de ski alpin donc
mais du trail des raquettes du ski de
randonnée et bien sûr de la luge c'est
simplement le pur plaisir plaisir
d'aller faire du ski de rando juste
après et d'emmener ma petite nièce
profiter des plaisirs de la neige mais
du coup c'est l'occasion de découvrir de
nouveaux sports
hier j'ai fait un peu de ski de fond
j'ai jamais fait donc ça sort un peu
aussi de nos sentiers battus nous on a
juste à attendre a finalement dans une
bonne situation n'est qu'aux clients
mais surtout pour les professionnels
c'est compliqué d'autant plus frustrant
pour les professionnels que l'hiver
dernier avait été compliqué d'un point
de vue météo et déjà écourté par lakovic
les conditions en ce début décembre sont
idéales et le domaine géromois 120
salariés lors de son pic d'activité
aurait pu être ouverts dans sa
quasi-totalité dès ce week-end pour
l'instant qu'on prend notre mal en
patience en
on continue à préparer les pistes en a
mis en place des bouées sur neige sur la
petite madeleine des activités de l'usch
sécurisé pour limiter les accidents et
limiter l'engorgement des hôpitaux en
est bien conscient de la situation selon
les saisons décembre peut représenter de
10 à 20% du chiffre d'affaires annuel
jusqu'à 25% pour les moniteurs de
l'école du ski français
ils sont soixante dix à gérardmer et
seulement 6 à travailler actuellement
entre la mauselaine et les bas rupts la
décision concernant les remontées
mécaniques sera réévalué le 11 décembre
dans le cadre d'une clause de revoyure
autre échéance très attendue plus
généralement pour les professionnels du
tourisme la levée des restrictions de
déplacement fixée normalement au 15
décembre les fêtes la sas annonce un peu
à peu compliqué mais on a quand même des
taux de réservation qui augmente un tout
petit peu la première semaine nous on
doit être à peu près à 60 % et la
deuxième semaine à 70% sur les locations
saisonnières
en attendant les prochaines annonces
gouvernementales la station de la
mauselaine à gérardmer sera ouverte dans
les mêmes conditions les mercredis
samedis et dimanches sachant que les
licenciés mineurs sportifs de haut
niveau et professionnels peuvent accéder
aux remontées mécaniques
nous allons prendre des nouvelles des
restaurants qui sont toujours fermés
vous le savez en moselle
en attendant de rouvrir leurs portes les
restaurateurs s'adaptent et tente de
trouver des solutions pour limiter les
pertes
beaucoup se sont mis à la livraison ou
la vente à emporter exemple à maroeuil
dans l'auberge de vaison un reportage de
nos confrères de via moselle tv regarder
depuis plus d'un mois
fini les dressages dans de belles
assiettes il n'y a qu'à remplir ces
petits récipients une mode contraintes
qui emporte la plupart des restaurateurs
dont bernard tenant de l'auberge de
vaison avec sa femme depuis près de 22
ans
moi je me vois pas devant la télé tous
les jours du matin au soir devant la
télé il faut que je fasse quelque chose
et puis toi quand il faut garder un lien
avec nos clients il faut que les clients
en face qu'on est là que commence à voir
partir
c'est toute une organisation qui a été
revu aujourd'hui la salle du restaurant
n'accueille plus de clients mais stocks
du matériel pouvait rien du tout et on a
juste un peu de mise en place pour
l'emporter par quelques cagettes
quelques boîtes bernard et christelle se
sont vite accommodés de ce nouveau mode
de fonctionnement
un coup de fil et les clients peuvent
récupérer leur plat quelques minutes
plus tard ce midi ils étaient une
vingtaine à se succéder
ils le savent l'avenir de l'auberge
passe aussi par eux au premier conflit
ne le savais pas et puis là on fait
toutes les semaines maintenant on vient
justement pour les soutenir parce que
voilà on apprécie bon et puis c'est très
bon une contribution qui malheureusement
est insuffisante
le manque à gagner reste de taille un
bon ben là aujourd'hui on a fait une
vingtaine de couverts
non non en temps normal on arrive à
40,50 le midi on le voit un peu moins le
week-end on travaille bien le fait moyen
reculer n'est pas de même
un miti qui doit pour le moment se
cramponner aux solutions alternatives
telles la vente à emporter
avant peut-être des jours plus joyeux ou
dans les salle leyrit résonneront à
nouveau autre idée cette fois en
bretagne où une restauratrice
quimpéroise a décidé de se montrer au
marché du samedi matin en compagnie de
quatre collègues à la fois pour se
montrer mais aussi pour capter de
nouveaux clients
regardez les faire leur premier marché
sous la pluie mais avec motivation
frédéric lorenzo pour la chaîne tébéo
sur place en bretagne regarder depuis le
29 octobre dernier ils n'ont plus le
droit de servir dans leurs restaurants
quatre restaurateurs de la rue du frout
à quimper ont donc décidé d'aller au
devant du public sur le marché du samedi
matin
moi je trouve que c'est assez important
de garder ce lien avec les clients de
toujours parler de dire qu'on est là que
ça va bien qu'on s'en sort comme on peut
ce que dans le dans la ferme et gérant
d'un restaurant on peut se retrouver
même nous de notre propre restaurant on
a découvert des choses qu'on n'était pas
peut-être pas capable de faire et qu'on
a réussi est capable le remporter nota
restaurant qui faisait zéro d'emporter
et aujourd'hui on faisait les amplitudes
d'emporter jusqu'à entre 40 50 commandes
par soif
petit plat foie gras bière ou vin les
clients se pressent et se veulent
solidaires toutes les semaines en fait
on essaie de faire travailler un
restaurateur et comme voilà j'avais vu
que il faisait je me suis dis bah c'est
l'occasion de venir les faire travailler
parce que je sais que ben voilà il pour
eux c'est compliqué en ce moment les
restaurants on avait l'habitude d'aller
régulièrement en famille à toi et ça
demande beaucoup pour tout vous dire
et puis on a envie aussi tu puisse
perdurer dans restaurateurs m'en vais
pouvoir les retrouver après cette crise
et donc c'est aussi une façon continue
les faire vivre
l'initiative de restaurateurs et
soutenue par la municipalité de cap vert
qui est comme elle peut les commerçants
à passer la crise alena qui vont plus
mal pour qui c'est plus difficile
difficile de mettre de l'énergie de se
relever et cela c'est cela que qu'il
faut pas oublier tout ce qui est bon à
prendre c'est toutes les initiatives
solidaires et créatives on est prêt tout
étudié en attendant une possible
réouverture de la restauration le 20
janvier prochain les restaurateurs
quimpérois espère rallier d'autres
collègues et une météo plus clémente
pour le marché samedi prochain une
rencontre à présent dans le grand jt des
territoires nous partons pour l'aube à
la rencontre de stéphane gérant d'un bar
il s'appelle le shamrock à 3 le premier
confinement fut bien sûr un choc pour
lui après avoir baissé les bras et il a
décidé de renouveler son concept de bar
et à trouver
vous allez le voir l'énergie de repartir
à zéro un reportage de canal 32 sur
place stéphane du buisson investi toutes
ses économies dans leurs prises de ce
bar à mai 2019 le premier confinement il
a vécu comme un coup dur
abasourdi ils baissent les bras et
s'isole durant deux mois et demi en
regardant la télévision en continu
on pense à l'argent au fait que l'on est
seul
et puis ce niveau c'était une carrière
difficile
grâce au soutien de ses amis si sa
situation est inchangée
il observe autrement et décide de
relancer une partie de son activité
grâce au click and collect cela ne
s'avère pas rentable
j'ai fait 500 euros de chiffre
d'affaires en à peu près un mois
loyer au début du 2ème confinement il
licencie l'unique salarié ait choisi de
profiter de la fermeture obligatoire
pour étendre à d'autres événements
culturels
le concept de son bar concert rue de la
cité à trois le salon de thé et salons
littéraires ici un bar à cocktails
bientôt et l'autre partie exposition de
peintures et lieux d'événements et de
concert d'après son expert-comptable son
activité devrait lui permettre de
bénéficier des 10000 euros dead
cette somme pourrait rembourser ces
nouveaux investissements qui tente de
minimiser
je réalise un petit bar avec des
palettes de récupération
j'étais maçon de l'électricité la
plomberie je sais pas faire il y aura
juste les artisans à payer aujourd'hui
chaque avancée leur motive davantage
lors de la réouverture
ils espèrent bénéficier de l'engouement
du public en attente de sortie et
soutenir les artistes
durant cette fermeture stéphane du
buisson reconstruit reste un doute
la date de réouverture il espère le 20
janvier 2021 vous êtes peut-être en
train de réaliser vos achats de noël une
période où la poste connaît évidemment
un pic de demande d'autant plus avec ce
confinement
alors c'est le rush pour envoyer au plus
vite vos présents regardez ce reportage
à cholet avec nos confrères de tlc la
chaîne locale du choletais
si certaines entreprises ont vu leur
activité s'amoindrir voix même s'
arrêter totalement en cette période de
confinement puis d'allègement du
confinement
ce n'est clairement pas le cas de la
poste encore moins en cette période de
fin d'année où les colis arrivent en
nombre
en général on compte 20 % de trafic
colis supplémentaires à l'approché des
fêtes
cette année les 30 % étaient dépassées
sans aucun problème
alors sur place on s'adapte les premiers
colis sont déjà là à 6h05
d'autres arrivent dix minutes plus tard
sur la plateforme de cholet tous les
codes postaux du secteur sont mélangés
alors il faut d'abord faire un tri puis
le replacer dans leur tournée avec un
itinéraire qui change tous les jours
pour les facteurs trafic organisation
sur le centre courrier de cholet ancolie
c'est une moyenne de 850 collision sur
début de la pire période nous étions à
un trafic moyen de 1200 colis jour et
fin décembre nous étions rendus à 2420
de piques période cette année
dès la fin octobre nous étions sur un
trafic à 1700 colis jours à partir du 16
novembre nous sommes passés sur un
trafic à 2800 collision hélas les
prévisions pour décembre c'est une
moyenne à 3500 colis avec des pics au
dessus de 4000 pour cette période de pic
11 véhicules supplémentaires ont été
loués la plateforme de cholet a fait
appel à quatorze intérimaire en plus une
information qui est loin d'être
anecdotique puisque rares sont les
entreprises qui embauchent encore des
intérimaires en ce moment et cela permet
à des personnes comme clément de mettre
un premier pied dans l'entreprise et
commencer une nouvelle carrière à passe
on a de la chance on a souvent de
travail et surtout dans cette période où
déjà habituellement c'est une des plus
grosses pertes de l'année par rapport au
fait mais encore plus cette année avec
le confinement ou où les volumes on
doublait quasiment dernier point où
dernier conseil des facteurs si
toutefois vous voulez envoyer un colis
un peu fragile il ne faut pas lésiner
sur les protections à l'intérieur il
faut aussi bien renseigné le
destinataire est l'expéditeur
histoire que l'objet arrive en bon état
et au bon endroit
et oui noël approchent c'est l'occasion
pour nos villes de revêtir leurs plus
belles illuminations et décorations
regardez ces images qui nous viennent du
limousin c'est la chaîne 7 à limoges
nouveau partenaire du grand jt des
territoires qui nous envoyait ces images
qui nous redonne un peu le sourire
dans ce climat pesant en raison de la
crise sanitaire
bonjour à ses nouveaux confrères donc de
7 à limoges qui rejoignent le grand jt
des territoires cette belle histoire
maintenant qui pourrait être une
histoire de noël
en tout cas elle pourrait donner le
sourire à beaucoup de l'albanie à
l'occitanie voici le parcours hors du
commun de goran arrivé il ya quatre ans
sur le territoire il était considéré
comme un mineur isolé il a été pris en
charge par les services sociaux et il a
décroché une formation en apprentissage
au collège emile-alain de carcassonne et
s'illustre dans la cuisine française
cette année lui sa recette apparaissent
dans le livre d'agri locale un guide qui
met en avant les produits locaux
à rayonnement international son histoire
est racontée par les équipes devient
occitanie sur place regardez comme
chaque mercredi à l'heure du repas
le réfectoire du collège emile-alain à
carcassonne évident pourtant on cuisine
on s'active le chef cuistot jean jacques
et ses trois employés s'apprêtent à
faire un exercice de dressage de placer
le principal intéressé c'est lui julian
il a 20 ans il est un apprentissage dans
cet établissement depuis trois ans
pourtant rien ne prédestinait ce jeune
albanais à être ici aujourd'hui je suis
arrivé en france en 2016 j'avais 16 ans
et demi ça se passe pas trop bien avec
la famille du coup je me suis barré
arrivée en france l'adolescent obtient
le statut de mineurs non accompagnés
un statut dont bénéficie automatiquement
les mineurs étrangers isolés présents
sur le territoire
prise en charge par un service de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance et il finit par
atterrir à carcassonne je suis arrivé
j'ai été accueilli par conseil
départemental de l'aude
après on me proposait un contrat
informations des cuisines
j'ai fait un monde ce stage au collège
de bram le chef de grande
il m'a proposé un contrat
d'apprentissage je ne suis pas arrêté
maintenant je vais à tamponner également
aux menaces julian obtient alors un
statut de travailleur indépendant
un parcours exceptionnel et qui ne
s'arrête pas là cette année un de ses
plats été sélectionné pour figurer dans
le livre de recettes d'agri locale une
plateforme qui promeut les produits
locaux
ils gagnent grâce au fbi prêche un plat
traditionnel albanais c'est surtout
cette configuration je dirais
d'adaptation d'un produit albanais et
d'une recette albanaise à la sauce
audoise à médina pays cathare et donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui a fortement
interpellé le jury national
une recette albanaise avec des produits
audois finalement ce plat c'est un peu
l'histoire de julian celle d'une
intégration réussie
nous partons au mans en sorte à présent
cette ville fait partie des 15 premières
de france a expérimenté la 5g
l'opérateur orange à d'ailleurs inauguré
ses antennes dans quatre communes du
département
alors pourquoi ce choix pour cet
opérateur et quels sont les résultats de
ce test grandeur nature
explications dans ce reportage d'hélène
galiana pour vient lmtv sartre sur place
le mont coulaines alone et yvré-l'évêque
voilà les quatre premières communes
sarthoises est couverte par le réseau 5
g l'opérateur orange a choisi d'ouvrir
ses lignes en premier lieu sur notre
territoire
la raison rapidement dans notre
département le réseau 4g risquent la
saturation car il est de plus en plus
sollicités orange note une hausse de la
demande de près de 40% les réseaux 4g
sont utilisés chaque année beaucoup plus
que l'année précédente
on estime ces mêmes parce qu'on estime
son voix sur les réseaux qu'ils y
entrent plus 40 et plus 50 % d'usagers
d'internet notamment et des applications
en plus chaque année sur le réseau
mobile
donc les réseaux 4g c'est vrai au mans
seront saturées d'ici 2022 saturé ça
veut dire une dégradation de la qualité
de service sur ces réseaux mobiles on ne
veut pas que ça arrive et la 5g vient
aussi en relais pour permettre
elle apportera beaucoup plus de vitesse
de qualité de service mais elle permet
aussi de désaturer le réseau kadji et
tous ceux qui voudront rester un temps
pull ou sur ces réseaux 4g pourrait
continuer à avoir une excellente qualité
de service
ce qui ne serait plus le cas si la 5g
n'arrivait pas à partir de 2020 pour
naviguer sur les réseaux 5g il faudra
penser à deux petits détails malgré tout
avoir tout d'abord un téléphone
compatible et souscrire un forfait
nous partons maintenant dans la rubrique
écorégions pour la charente-maritime
dans ce grand jt des territoires à la
rencontre d'une société qui s'appelle
sharks industries une société
spécialisée dans les robots industriels
michel picaud bonjour vous nous en dit
plus sur cette pme très made in france
qui commence à rayonner dans le monde et
même jusque dans l'espace
bonjour cyril bonjour à toutes et à tous
shark robotics a été créé en 2016 ils
sont installés à deux pas de la rochelle
c'est là qu'ils fabriquent entièrement
leurs robots industriels jusqu'à la
batterie mission de leur robot éloigné
l'homme des zones à risques on les
trouve donc dans les domaines de la
sécurité de la défense de l'industrie de
l'énergie et dû nucléaire est plus
surprenant en 2016 lors de l' incendie
de notre dame de paris
c'est leur robot pompiers qui est entré
seul dans le monument flammes où la
température a atteint les 800 degrés 10
heures d'intervention pour son robot qui
ont permis notamment d'éviter
l'effondrement de la cathédrale et de
sauvegarder de nombreuses oeuvres d'art
grâce aux frappes chirurgicales du robot
à savoir la détection rapide des points
chauds avec sa caméra thermique et du
refroidissement avec un canon à eau et
le robot est ressorti intacte en 2020 il
décide d'adapter leurs robots pour enfin
en robot de décontamination capable de
micro pulvériser des solutions
désinfectantes sur vingt mille mètres
carrés de surface ont seulement trois
heures
enfin et ce n'est pas fini la pme
française a été contacté par l'américain
boston dynamics et leader incontesté de
la robotique mondial pour un partenariat
technologique toujours dans le cadre de
la lutte contre la copie 19 les sharks
robotics 40 personnes a donc fait son
entrée sur le marché américain et
envisage désormais d'envoyer certains de
ces robots pour des missions dans
l'espace
qui a dit que nous n'avions pas des
talents dans le territoire merci michel
picaud nous vous retrouvons dans une
prochaine édition du grand jt des
territoires pour nous présenter des
entreprises qui font rayonner le savoir
faire français
nous partons maintenant soleil nous
partons pour monaco avec ce reportage
consacré aux panneaux solaires qui vous
permettent de contribuer à la transition
énergétique de la principauté
sandrine et alexandre hadmar
agonie de monaco info se sont rendus sur
plusieurs toits de la principauté afin
d'en savoir plus sur ce mode de
fonctionnement et surtout sur les
avantages de ces panneaux solaires on
part pour monaco ces opérations
lorsqu'il s'agit de bâtiments publics
sont donc réalisés par le smb elle se
trouve clairement un peu partout de
fontvieille avec l'église saint-nicolas
entre autres au larvotto en passant par
la condamine ou encore le jardin
exotique des exemples concrets de
l'engagement du gouvernement
princier en matière de transition
énergétique débutons ici au sommet de
l'église du sacré coeur aux monnaies
getty si on n'a pas une rénovation
énergétique du bâtiment sert qu'on a
installé une pompe à chaleur en
remplacement de la chaudière à gaz pour
éliminer l'énergie fossile et on a
également installé un ballon
thermodynamique en remplacement d'un
chauffe-eau électrique qui est moins
onéreux et moins d'une heure du banc est
également on installer un des panneaux
solaires photovoltaïques
on arrive à atteindre une environ 20%
d'autosuffisance pour l'église sacré
coeur en consommation électrique
non loin de là le quartier du jardin
exotique abritait déjà des installations
solaires sur l'école d'airé voir depuis
peu viennent s'ajouter les panneaux
posés sur le toit de la villa paloma
l'un des deux lieux qui composent le
nmnm est des panneaux haute performance
dernière génération un peu plus bas
l'école de la condamine ou 69 modules
sur 113 mètres carrés sont désormais
opérationnels la particularité de ces
panneaux photovoltaïques c'est qu'ils
sont d'une teinte verte
on a choisi cette étape avec la avec
l'urbanisme pour qu'il s'intègre
parfaitement au quartier de la condamine
de l'autre côté de la principauté sur
les hauteurs de rockville le
photovoltaïque vous le voyez est aussi
d'actualité au foyer de l'enfance
princesse charlene au larvotto la
société monégasque des eaux figure sur
la liste des bâtiments ou des panneaux
haute performance dernière génération
ont pu être installés 136 précisément
elle la pose des panneaux solaires est
donc un exemple majeur de la politique
environnementale menée par la
principauté sous l'impulsion du prince
albert deux éléments essentiels en lien
direct avec ses panneaux la
centralisation des informations de
production et à une gtc regroupe toutes
les informations des installations
techniques d'un bâtiment et là en
l'occurrence pour le photovoltaïque nous
regroupons toute la production tout
l'état des onduleurs de fonctionnement
des onduleurs pour savoir s'il
fonctionne correctement pour savoir si
que chaque panneau fonctionne
correctement et surtout pour conter
cette énergie produite réinjecter et
savoir la quantifier sur la globalité de
la principauté de monaco
direction la bretagne maintenant dans ce
grand jt des territoires à saint georges
de reintembault où un couple a racheté
un ancien lycée agricole pour en faire
un lieu culturel mais également vous
allez le voir leur maison
et oui c'est une idée qu'est né pendant
le premier confinement une tâche immense
les attend mais l'engouement sur les
réseaux sociaux et également de leur
voisin leur donne du baume au coeur
regardez ce reportage nos confrères de
tvr sur place à rennes le bocage cet
ancien lycée agricole de la commune de
saint georges de reintembault s'apprête
à prendre un nouveau départ avec son
épouse
rod maurice vient de faire l'acquisition
du bâtiment et de son terrain un projet
né à la suite du premier confinement ces
deux professionnels du milieu culturel
qui ne travaille plus depuis mars se
projette sans mal dans ce lieu malgré
l'ampleur des travaux à venir ce
bâtiment sera avant tout notre maison on
va utiliser deux salles de classe donc
ça fait un peu près l'équivalent de 140
m² et le reste va être vide et au lieu
de laisser le vide ainsi aidé en fait on
va plutôt tenter de transformer ce qui
reste un énorme friscia le culturel le
bloc de 1800 mètres carrés est
désaffecté depuis 1991 son état s'est
détérioré au fil des pillages du squat
et du manque d'entretien
par endroits la nature il a même repris
ses droits où on tombe collectivités on
devenait aussi assez un pied en par
rapport au devenir de l'espace parce que
c'est un lieu privé mais pour lesquelles
on a fini par prendre un arrêté de péril
puisque le lieu de mener quand même
dangereux donc c'est vrai que le
précédent mandat et ce lieu-là était
plus à un lieu source d'inquiétude que
de satisfactions mais voilà comme quoi
les choses peuvent se renverser
les travaux risquent de prendre du temps
d'autant que le couple d'acquéreurs
prévoit d'en réaliser une partie lui
même mais il ne manque pas
d'encouragements le profil instagram
qu'ils viennent de créer pour partager
leurs projets compte déjà plus de 38000
abonnés voit la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci
votre fidélité merci de nous avoir suivi
sur vos chaînes locales et régionales et
sur tv5 monde et rendez vous pour une
prochaine édition
au revoir à tous
[Musique]